On behalf of all Ukrainians, I am grateful to all
metal workers whose hearts do not remain
indifferent to evil and support help
in defense. Today we discussed
our cooperation, in particular, security,
military, there are very important decisions regarding the
protection of our
sky.  Firms and media there are aggressors,
corpses gave the territory of Ukraine, Zelensky
among all I want to thank you for helping
to save people's lives and everything we do
for the sake of security, we do it together, and this is
what protects our Ukrainian families,
protects children, protects the homes of our
civilians, the lives of soldiers. Maybe someone who has
not seen  what is the aggression of Russia, it seems
that it can be anyway, how will it all
end? Who will win,
but this question is about when finally
Russian bombs will simply
stop destroying Ukrainian forces and
every Ukrainian family will be sure
that their home or apartment will not be destroyed by one or
another rocket  the remote cabin will be destroyed by
artillery